Dear fellow scholars. This is two minute papers with Dr. [inaudible]
. In the last few years, we have seen a bunch of new AI based techniques that were specialized in generating new and novel images. This is mainly done through
learning based
techniques. Typically a generative adversarial network, again in short, which is an architecture where a generator neural network creates new images and passes it to a discriminator network, which learns to distinguish real photos from these fake generated images. The two networks learn and improve together and generate better and better images over time. What do you see here is a set of results created with
a technique by the name psycho
. Again, this could even translate daytime into nighttime images. Re-imagine
the picture of a horse as if it were a zebra and more, we can also use it for
star transfer the problem where we have to
input images, one for content and one for style.
And as you see here, the output would be a nice mixture of the two.
However, if we use cycle GaN for this kind of style transfer,
we'll get something like this.
The goal was to learn the style of a select set of famous illustrators of
children's books by providing an input image with their work.
So what do you think about the results while the style is indeed completely
different from the source,
but the algorithm seems a little too heavy handed and did not leave the content
itself intact. Let's have a look at another result with a previous technique.
Maybe this will do better. This is due again,
which refers to a paper by the name and supervise dual learning for image to
image translation. This uses two Gans to perform image translation,
where one GaN learns to translate for instance, from day to night,
while the other learns the opposite night, two day translation.
This among other advantages makes things very efficient.
But as you see here in these cases, it preserves the content of the image,
but perhaps a little too much because the style itself does not appear too
prominently in the output images.
So cycle GaN is good at transferring style,
but a little less so for content and do again is good at preserving the
content, but sometimes adds too little of the style to the image.
And now hold onto your papers because this new technique by the name Gunilla
offers us these results, the content is intact checkmark,
and the style goes through really well. Check Mark it,
preserves the content and transfers the style at the same time.
Excellent.
One of the many key reasons as to why this happens is the usage of skip
connections,
which help preserve the content information as we travel deeper into the neural
network. So finally,
let's put our money where our mouth is and take a bunch of illustrators Marvel
at their unique style and then apply it to photographs and see how
the algorithm stacks up against other previous works.
Wow. I love these beautiful results.
These comparisons really show how good the new Gunilla technique is at
preserving content and note that these are distinct artistic styles that are
really difficult to reproduce. Even for humans.
It is truly amazing that we can perform such a thing. Algorithmically,
don't forget that the first star transfer paper appeared approximately three
to three and a half years ago, and now we have come a long, long way.
The pace of progress in machine learning research is truly stunning while we are
looking at some more amazing results this time around only from Gunilla.
I will note that the authors also made a user study with 48 people who
favored this against yes techniques
and perhaps leaving the best for last.
It can even draw in the style of [inaudible]. I bet they're
a bunch of Miyazaki fans watching. So let me know in the comments, what you think about these results, what a time to be alive.
And this episode has been supported by weights and biases in this post.
They show you how to easily iterate on models by visualizing and comparing
experiments. In real time.
Also weights and biases provides tools to track your experiments in your deep
learning project. Their system is designed to save you a ton of time and money,
and it is actively used in projects at prestigious labs,
such as open AI Toyota research GitHub and more.
And the best part is that if you're an academic or have an open source project,
you can use their tools for free. It really is as good as it gets,
make sure to visit them through wnb.com/papers,
or just click the link in the video description.
And you can get a freedom or today are thanks to weights and biases for their
longstanding support and for helping us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous support. And I'll see you next time.